[Music]
Disney is about to lose copyright in
Mickey Mouse that's right Mickey Mouse
literally the most iconic character that
they've ever created one that they
themselves claim is worth $15
billion and they're doing it all on
purpose but why well the answer is both
shocking and kind of Genius I'm Jake
Watson lawyer producer and YouTuber with
Corridor crew let's get into the
[Music]
issue so what is a copyright why does
Mickey Mouse have one that's almost 100
years old how is he going to lose it and
why does that matter a copyright is the
right of an author of an artistic or
scientific work to exploit that work
without anybody else being able to do so
this is known as the exclusive right but
the big picture reason the actual reason
why copyright law exists isn't just to
protect authors the bigger reason is
that it's to promote the progress of
human knowledge so copyright
incentivizes people to go out to try
things to learn things to make things to
discover things and in exchange ensures
them that at the end of the rainbow they
will be able to exploit the fruit of
their labor without it being stolen from
them but the other side of copyright is
that when a work is useful enough when
it is truly useful to the benefit of our
culture it becomes part of our popular
culture and in order for human knowledge
to be expanded upon over time you need
to allow people who come along long
after the original author to take that
original work and expand upon it to
build upon it so that overall as a
species humanity is better off tomorrow
than we are right now now Mickey Mouse
has a copyright because he is in essence
a work of art and creativity a
contribution if you will to human
knowledge and well that contribution is
owned by the Walt Disney Company I own
all this now in fact Disney owns so many
versions of Mickey Mouse it's more like
Mickey mice but the very first version
the OG version of Mickey Mouse house
that Disney first ever published was in
1928 with a little film called Steamboat
Willie and the copyright for that film
lasts 95 years more on how we got there
in a minute what it means right now is
that on January 1st 2024 Disney is going
to lose their copyright in this very
first version of Mickey Mouse but what's
more is that this will set off a
timeline where over the coming years
several other versions of Mickey Mouse
and several other iconic Disney
characters will also lose their
copyrights so how are Mickey and his
friends going to lose something that
they've held for almost 100 years all
copyrights every single one is limited
by time and when the copyright
protection on a work runs out the work
enters the public domain now the public
domain isn't like a repository for lost
Disney characters or something it's just
this idea that when the time runs out
the exclusive right held by the
copyright owner no longer applies the
thing is once a work enters the public
domain it stays there forever now as you
might imagine this is incredibly
significant because it allows literally
anybody to take the original work to use
it and even to resell it without the
permission of the copyright owner now of
course Disney would be concerned with
this they don't want other people going
out and selling their work without their
permission do we have a problem no sir
no Mr Mouse but that's not what's
shocking here what's shocking is that
the copyright in Steamboat Willie was
supposed to expire 40 years ago now as
you probably well know Walt Disney
started creating some of the most iconic
characters ever in the 1920s 30s and 40s
and all of these characters were
protected for 56 years from the date of
publication under the rules of the 1909
act so let's just do some rough math
here 1920s plus what 56 years of
protection leaves you roughly where late
1970s oh that's weird look there's a
footnote here the Copyright Act of
1976 oddly convenient Disney you see
with their old friend Willie only being
protected under the rules of the 1909
act his copyright was set to expire in
1984 which would also set off that
timeline where numerous other characters
that Disney owned would also expire and
enter the public domain so what was
Disney to do well let's see you've got a
multi-billion dollar character about to
be pushed into the public domain oh yeah
that's right they did exactly what you
think they did which was to embark on a
very serious lobbying effort to get
Congress to pass the Copyright Act of
1976 and I got to say the effort worked
because the ACT extended copyright to
characters created before 1978 for a
total of 75 years an additional 19 years
above and beyond the original rules of
the 1909 act see mini money can buy
happiness and laws ha I don't want to
completely undermine the 1976 Copyright
Act by saying that it was entirely
because of Disney I mean there were
several other legitimate reasons why it
was created in past and efforts for its
development began in the early 1960s it
also codified the fair use Doctrine
which is awesome but also Disney and
look well it is nearly impossible to
obtain comprehensive information on
Disney's lobbying efforts from 1960 to
1975 Disney even today self-reports that
they spend between $4 and $5 million per
year on federal lobbying alone which
doesn't sound like all that much but
when you consider that this is
self-reporting that they claimed in 1997
their mouse was worth $8 billion and
they have numerous other connection with
very influential lobbying groups like oh
I don't know the National Association of
public broadcasters the ncta internet
and television Association and the
Motion Picture Association of America
look I'm not blaming them I'm just
saying they like their Mouse that's why
in 1998 Disney once again lobbied
Congress this time to pass the copyright
term extension act the copyright term
extension act did exactly as the name
implies and that was to amend the 1976
act to expand copyright protection by an
additional 20 years for a total of 95
years once again only for works created
before 1978 now Disney's influence here
cannot be overstated for starters one of
the more derisive terms for the ACT was
just to call it the Mickey Mouse
protection act that's probably because
in addition to self-reporting $6.3
million in lobbying efforts for the ACT
Disney also made significant campaign
contributions to key people involved in
the development and passage of the act
by some reports 18 of of the 25 Congress
people who originally sponsored the bill
received
$800,000 campaign contributions directly
from Disney including the Senate
Majority Leader at the time of course if
you're going to spend that kind of money
I think it actually there's a reversal
there and you're now required to go out
and take them out to dinner first which
is exactly what then Disney CEO Michael
Eisner did with Senate Majority Leader
Trent lot at the time to discuss you
know I don't know the development and
passage of the ACT oh I uh don't think
that's legal Minnie and it worked this
effort bought them a 20-year extension
on all of their copyrights created
before 1978 when on October 27th 1998
Bill Clinton signed the bill into law
now it's at this point in Disney's
Journey that I just I need to stop for a
second because what they did here is
really dumb they did not use today's
sponsor Squarespace you see Squarespace
has been building and improving their
platform for so many years now there so
much more than just beautiful
award-winning templates and 24/7
award-winning customer service of course
they still have those things but
Squarespace today right here right now
is an all-in-one platform for building
your business and growing your audience
online as all the big studios know it's
all about the analytics now well guess
what Squarespace is one step ahead of
them all with best in the game analytics
you can understand what your sales are
what your views are where your audience
is coming from and make changes to
improve your site that you can better
tailor your website to your audience
over time now think about that Mouse
that's right I'm using Mouse now because
I don't want to mix the trademarks
together and get anybody upset but you
all know who I'm talking about and if
that wasn't enough Squarespace has the
Squarespace video studio app which
allows you to edit videos seamlessly and
share them with your audience now look
consider this do you have multiple
social media accounts well Squarespace
can allow you to connect and manage them
all from your Squarespace website a way
to get one one message out to a bunch of
different people on a bunch of different
platforms and I think some other people
we've been talking about could benefit
from this too so here's my professional
legal opinion on this whole thing if
you're interested in getting 10% of your
first purchase of a website or domain go
to squarespace.com Corridor crew or just
click the link in the description below
now what I'm about to tell you next is a
shocker this brings us to today where 95
years later the very first version of
Mickey Mouse is is about to enter the
public domain so this naturally begs the
question why hasn't Disney done anything
about it this time I mean can't they
just Lobby Congress again get their
copyrights extended and everyone goes on
as normal well yeah they could and there
are several reasons for why they aren't
look I thought about going into all of
them okay you have the constitutionality
of effectively Perpetual copyright
extensions you have the social backlash
that could possibly ensue if they embark
on another large lobbying effort you
even have trademark which I will talk
about just a little bit but they all
pale in comparison to the real reason
why they chose to do nothing about this
and the real reason is that because over
the last 25 years Disney has gotten so
big that it is no longer worth the time
to extend copyright in Mickey Mouse it
literally is not worth it to them
anymore that sounds simple oh yeah they
got big as a company Disney Mickey
doesn't mean anything to no look I don't
think you realize how big Disney has
gotten since 1995 the period right
before the copyright term extension act
Disney has made 22 major Acquisitions
which have dramatically Shrunk the value
of Mickey Mouse as a total portion of
their entire business compare that to
just four Acquisitions made in their
entire existence before 1995 but that's
not what's truly staggering here what's
truly staggering is that the value of
these Acquisitions when adjust
for inflation that means everything I'm
about to tell you is in today's real
dollars the value of the Acquisitions
before 1995 were worth $200 million and
the value of the Acquisitions made after
1995 are worth
$160
billion that's an $ 800 times increase
in acquisition value from before 1995 to
after 1995 800 times for comparison
here's a little chart of Mickey Mouse
worth his $15.4 billion in today's money
next to some of the major Acquisitions
Disney has made since 1995 are you ready
1996 Disney buys ABC and ESPN for 19
billion 06 Disney buys Pixar for 75
billion 09 Disney buys Marvel for 4
billion 2012 Disney buys Lucas film for
4 billion 2019 Disney buys 21st Century
Fox for a staggering 71.3 billion and on
November 6th of this year Disney
announced an $8.6 billion deal to
acquire full control of Hulu so now they
own ABC ESPN Hulu 21st Century Fox Pixar
Marvel and Lucas Films and they've all
acquired them since
1995 Mickey who I am really strong no
you're not holy crap like like I wrote
this this is the seventh time I've gone
through this it still blows my mind
think about it this way even when Mickey
Mouse does enter the public domain say
you could go out there and you make
something really cool with Mickey Mouse
something well within your rice
something 100% in the manner that
copyright was intended to promote the
progress of Science and the useful Arts
cuz you even put the dang piece
somewhere that isn't directly owned or
heavily controlled by Disney oh but Jake
you could put it on YouTube yeah that's
a great idea it gives me another idea
the idea that in 2014 Disney bought
Maker Studios for a casual 500 million
and it owned 60,000 partnered channels
at the time now granted that deal went
sideways and I think Phila Franco owns
it now but look that's not the point the
point is that now today in this world
Disney is an absolute Behemoth and
that's kind of what makes this
terrifying but also genius because it's
like they've just spent the last 25
years silently and diligently working
away in preparation for this exact
moment which is probably exactly what
they did I I mean they're literally
choosing not to even attempt to extend
copyright protection on the most iconic
character they've ever created because
well like he's he's truly Mouse sized to
them now like he's like a little baby
boy Mouse little Mickey boy come here
get a little hug Mickey when I started
researching this video I really wanted
to say that it was a win for the people
to have Mickey Mouse enter the public
domain because it shows that the law is
still working in this country but Disney
is playing such a different game of
chess that calling this a win simply
because Disney chose not to do anything
about it is like saying you won the race
because you ran on a post let's be frank
Disney is about as threatened by
Steamboat Willie entering the public
domain as Shaquille O'Neal is threatened
by Kevin
Hart oh and one more tiny small itty
itty little bitty thing here uh Disney's
also not going to do anything thing
about extending their copyrights because
they still own trademarks in every
character that they've ever produced and
the best thing about trademarks for them
at least in this situation is that
trademarks never expire but don't worry
trademark is a vastly different area
than copyright law so it's not like
Disney's going to start going around and
using their trademarks effectively as
copyrights it it it just means that
they're going to try now look on a more
serious note in my opinion it is a good
thing that Mickey Mouse is is entering
the public domain even if it's largely
due to the fact that Disney just chose
not to do anything about it for 95 years
Disney has held the exclusive right in
the character of Mickey Mouse but Mickey
Mouse is so much more than a character
now he's he's a part of our popular
culture whether you like it or not he's
here to stay and I'm sure that his
success is well beyond Walt Disney's
wildest dreams and to be fair it's
because of the hard work that Disney has
put into that character which has made
made him so influential over all these
years but when we remind ourselves that
the purpose of copyright is to promote
the progress of Sciences and useful Arts
so that those who come long after the
authors May pick up that work and expand
upon it and build upon it so that
humanity is better off tomorrow than we
are right now I think it's time to start
building and honestly I think the Walt
Disney Company knows this too and after
researching this topic here's my take on
it Disney just did what any other
well-managed and well-positioned Company
would do in their circumstances they
changed how valuable Mickey Mouse was to
them without changing their values and
honestly you've got to commend them for
that if you like this video and you want
to see another one just like it I did
one on the legality of AI art right here
otherwise you can post a comment below
and let me know what other topics you'd
like me to get into on this lawyer
explains series oh and just one more
thing if you're interested in seeing
Steamboat Willie for the first time in
the public domain just come to the
corridor YouTube channel at midnight on
January 1st see you
later